bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous ce
soir en direct sur rt france francis
palombes je me tourne vers vous le quoi
qu'il en coûte français s -clef assez
généreux tout simplement pour commencer
depuis le 20 mars 2020 le gouvernement
français s'est lancé dans un soutien
auprès des entreprises très important
mais en france quoi qu'on dise quoi que
l'on puisse toujours s'est quittés parce
que tout peut s'améliorer on constate
quand même que on a commencé à aider les
très petites entreprises
nous avons eu un rayon d'action pour
aider soutenir éviter la faillite d'un
très grand nombre d'entreprises pour les
plus petites d'entre elles mêmes celles
qui font moins de deux cent mille euros
de chiffre d'affaires ont été soutenus
en permanence jusqu'à présent et ça va
continuer ça va se renforcer
nous avons bien sûr des catégories
socioprofessionnelles plus que l d'acter
sont au bord de la détresse s'ils sont
sinoti sont fermés depuis plusieurs mois
c'est pas des semaines c'est des mois
donc le gouvernement français n'a fait
que renforcer ses soutiens et ses aides
alors dire que on est les mauvais élèves
de je pense que ce serait complètement
injuste ce n'est pas le cas on peut
encore faire mieux nous la confédération
des commerçants de france indépendant
nous demandons à ce que l'aide auprès
des entreprises les petites entreprises
que je représente s'effectue y compris
pour ceux qui c'est vrai c'est une
grande chance que notre gouvernement et
est vite et tous les jours un peu plus
le confie nombre total c'est très très
important pour les entreprises
françaises
mais ceux qui restent ouverts ont
également des grosses baisses de chiffre
d'affaires le couvre-feu n'est pas
neutre vous savez les soldes ont été
moins bonne que d'habitude non pas parce
qu'elles ont été reportés surtout pas
mais parce que il ya le contexte un
climat
ambiant très difficile donc voila mon
constat l'état et la soutenir les
entreprises
l'aspect sale terre on pourrait en
discuter davantage il ya eu deux pas en
avant trois pas en arrière il ya eu des
phases très difficiles concernant
sanitaire mais je ne suis pas là pour
juger l'aspect sanitaire
mais en ce qui concerne le plan
économique il est quand même au rendez
vous pour soutenir nos entreprises et je
le répète je le répète avec force x y
compris des très petites entreprises est
d'accord fabrice sakoun alors j'ai
partiellement d'accord effectivement le
plan de soutien aux entreprises est
important et on l'a eu mais mon nomades
ou même bénéficié d'un bon oeil dans ma
société
puisqu'on a bénéficié entre autres du
chômage partiel par exemple qui est un
dispositif absolument déterminant pour
les entreprises en particulier pour les
entreprises de services
après je sais qu'en france on aime bien
s'auto flageller et toujours dire qu'on
est les plus mauvais qu'on est les
derniers de l'europe on est les derniers
etc
il ne faut pas oublier une chose c'est
que on part d'un autre niveau
la conso comparé par exemple aux
américains qui ont investi froid huit ou
neuf points du pib dans le soutien aux
entreprises à théo d'ailleurs et aux
ménages
mais il faut voir d'où partent les états
unis aux états unis vous n'avez
absolument aucun l'amortisseur sociaux
quasiment aucun en france on a déjà un
niveau de soutien général de l'économie
et les méninges qui est très important
nous avons la sécurité sociale nous
avons effectivement les allocations
familiales nous avons le soutien aux
entreprises et du dispositif de toutes
sortes
donc peut-être qu'effectivement le plan
est moins ambitieux que dans d'autres
pays mais la réalité c'est qu'on parle
beaucoup alors justement vous comparez à
la situation
de la france avec les etats unis le
royaume uni si on va en parler mais par
rapport aux autres pays européens
l'italie l'allemagne on voit que c'est
des plans de relance sont à peu près au
même niveau mais tout de même il ya une
réponse en france qui était en dessous
quand même de ses voisins sans repères
comment l'expliquer en fait la démarche
de valeur et moi je me permets de le
d'intervenir senio marge de manoeuvre il
ne faut pas oublier que cette crise
intervient après la crise et gilet jaune
après des grèves qui ont été absolument
catastrophique pour l'économie
et nous avons en général économique est
déjà qu'ils étaient déjà en retrait dont
quand on parle de plan de relance
quand il ya onze ans mais le préfixe
heureuse devant ce qui voudrait dire
qu'effectivement on a déjà lancé quelque
chose mais en fait on était à mon avis
une économie qui était déjà en
difficulté relativement à l'arrêt donc
il est évident qu'on a on avait moins de
marge de manoeuvre que les allemands par
exemple ils ont beaucoup plus de marge
de manoeuvre financière et non peu ils
n'ont pas les déficits publics que l'ona
ils n'ont pas déficit du commerce
extérieur comme on a 7 et n'oublions pas
que l'allemagne est un pays de
producteurs alors que nous n'avons
renoncé malheureusement à produire sur
notre territoire nous sommes un pays de
consommateurs
ça change tout en termes de capacité à
relancer et est justement sont un pays
du de consommateurs et vendeurs
producteur francis palombes et la faute
à qui écoutez la faute à qui d'abord la
faute ne peut pas être qu'un seul
gouvernement qui a pris ses fonctions il
ya trois ans et déjà il faut être
logique
alors c'est vrai que nous veut nous
revenons de loin comme l'a dit monsieur
un colin et jose colle parfaitement ses
propos je m'associe à lyon nous
travaillons régulièrement avec le medef
avec d'autres organisations
professionnelles c'est vrai nos
représentants ne représentant pas
majoritairement les mêmes entreprises
que le medef
puis vous savez le monde de l'entreprise
c'est une grande famille et il faut pas
opposer les uns aux autres et et je
pense que en ce qui concerne notre pays
il y avait il ya eu des lacunes il ya
des lacunes certes mais je pense que
c'est surtout pas sur le plan économique
et quand monsieur un collège où rappelle
quand même et c'est important que nous
venons de vivre trois crises succès nous
sommes à la troisième prise successive
la plus importante avec le kobe 19
mais les filets jaunes nous ont beaucoup
affecté et les grèves sur les retraites
également donc je pense que l'état
français à mener quand même au stade de
soutenir les loyers des entreprises qui
sont fermés comme l'événementiel comme
les restaurants ont créé en charge
certaines échéances vis-à-vis des
fournisseurs
il faut quand même en prendre note et
c'est vrai l'amortisseur social
nous l'avons vu n'est ce pas monsieur la
colère en 2008 si le président sarkozy
n'avait pas eu cet amortisseur social
qui était partie de l'adn de la france
peut-être que les choses se seraient
passées beaucoup moins bien
il ya quand même l'effet cathartique qui
se plaignent notamment les restaurateurs
qui beaucoup disent que les que les
aides ne sont pas suffisantes aussi bien
quand même
oui mais vous avez raison madame je vous
dis pas non plus je viens de vous le
dire d'ailleurs les consoles les
restaurateurs sont très très affecté
mais je vous assure gélules deux
fédérations professionnelles qui
adhèrent à la confédération des
commerçants de france si c'est pas tous
les deux jours ils sont en permanence à
bercy avec l'excellent ministre
nouvellement des pme et du commerce
alain griset avec bruno le maire ils
sont sur la brèche tous les jours pour
avancer pour renforcer pour améliorer
les aides et les faire s'adapter aux
circonstances qui évolue parce que si
les barres et le variant du virus est là
si le virus évolue et bien la situation
des entreprises évoluent également
et il faut les soutenir il faut les
écouter on nous écoute beaucoup et
j'espère que ça doit continuer
ça va continuer sinon la cire et à
lâcher prise mais il n'y a surtout pas
de raison et bien bien évidemment on
pourrait enregistrer des faillites des
faillites très nombreuses du chômage
enfin tout ce que l'on espère pas et
s'adresse à tous lorsque le gouvernement
dit qu'il soutient totalement l'économie
c'est vrai ou c'est faux est ce que est
ce qu'on peut mieux faire
on ne peut pas dire que c'est faux part
qui revient il ya un soutien général
après le problème je pense que c'est un
problème de méthode d'une part et de
dénoncer de la manière dont on s'inscrit
que c'est à dire qu'en fait il ya deux
manières de soutenir une économie semble
au soutien en la mettant sous perfusion
et malheureusement un mal français pour
le coup là je vais m'inscrire planchot à
vouziers monsieur mettra ses pas mal
français ça qu'on accepte tendance à
mettre sous perfusion
on aime la dépense publique en france
mon âme la dépense publique non
constructive
moi je pense qu'il faudrait qu'on
profite de cette période qu'est super de
crise pour envisager le monde de demain
il ya le but c'est de bâtir sur la base
effectivement des difficultés que nous
rencontrons donc on pourrait se projeter
on pourrait par exemple il me revoir la
manière dont fonctionne le système
bancaire on parle pas du tout des
banques aujourd'hui mais faire que
l'état doit doit jouer son rôle mais
vous avez aussi effectivement les
banques doivent jouer le leur et
aujourd'hui les banques ont la
possibilité d'un sucre et dans
l'économie de l'argent elles ne font pas
du gâteau remet en état fada n'a pas de
frites avec même d'avancé sur les
grandes gagnantes les les banques
je serais pas capable de dire si ce sont
les grandes gagnantes en tout cas ce qui
est clair c'est qu'un certain nombre
effectivement de grands groupes qui eux
se s'inscrivent déjà dans la danse dans
le l'après crise et qui ont profité de
la crise pour se réorganiser se
restructurer par exemple oeuf beaucoup
plus faire appel aux digital qui a été
une chance pour nous en sommes nous par
exemple
donc je pense qu'il faut profiter de
cette crise pour se réinventer pour
réinventer un modèle de société parce
que je pense que cette crise n'est pas
complètement innocent par rapport au
modèle de société que nous avions tout
un modèle hyperconsommation de
développement outre cette lettre il faut
se poser les bonnes questions et
profiter pour investir dans l'avenir
alors vous voudrez je voudrais dire un
mot madame si vous le permettez monsieur
ah koon bien de parler du digital c'est
très important mais le digital nous
affecte également parce que la france
est là je suis et je devienne critique
la france doit régler le problème de
l'inéquité de l'injustice fiscale qui
sont qui est produite par les légats
femme par les grandes plateformes
numériques comme amazon alibaba qui ont
affecté le commerce physique qui a dû
fermer eux étaient ouverts leur
progression est astronomique et là je
pense que l'état doit vraiment
intervenir être internationaliste pour
vraiment rétablir l'équilibré rétablir
la l'équité d'ailleurs le président du
medef
monsieur roux de bézieux l'a dit comment
se fait-il que les entrepôts numérique
en france se crée au niveau d'amazon et
qui ne sont pas soumis à la tascom comme
tous les acteurs du commerce physique et
pourquoi les demandes d'autorisation
pour s'implanter en france en tant que
dépôts numériques qui sont des gros
entrepôt d entrepôt logistique de vente
à milliards et qui se dispense de la tva
là je pense me suis à coup nous avons
également je pense un combat commun à
mener contre et l'europe thierry breton
est en tête de ce combat pour rétablir
l'équilibré établir la justice par
rapport à cette concurrence qui devient
déloyale qui est très dangereuse et qui
pourrait dans les toutes prochaines
années
affaiblir considérablement notre
commerce physique auquel on tient même
temps je suis je ne peux pas ne pas agir
parce qu'effectivement sur le digital en
réalité d'abord il faut savoir une chose
qui est typiquement sur amazon faisait
beaucoup de petits commerçants à donner
accès à un marché énorme énorme qui m'a
choqué n'y avait pas que tu avant lequel
ils orga crée donc je tends vers un peu
ça je pense que la difficulté que
rencontrent aujourd'hui les petits
commerçants c'est la manière dont
certains centre-ville sont réorganisés
faible le niveau des charges sociales et
des charges patronales qui sont
astronomiques fait la réglementation je
pense que faire mais bien au delà de la
concurrence avec les gars fin pour
revenir justement à la réponse
budgétaire
tout à l'heure vous parlez des états
unis fabrice sakoun il ya aussi le
royaume uni la réponse à l'heure à peu
près entre 7 et 9 points du pib pour ces
deux pays
on en est loin nous mais finalement
c'est quelle est la meilleure voie à
suivre le long terme apparemment ce
serait ce que ce qu'a choisi la france
l'italie l'allemagne de des plans de
relance qui sont assez modérée pour
pouvoir donner une réponse sur le long
terme ou bien des plans d'urgence comme
au royaume uni ou aux états unis
là les plans d'urgence aux états unis
vous avez deux sont deux pays qui ont le
même modèle le même modèle de société le
même des économique d'un modèle
effectivement qui est ultra libéral dans
lequel il ya très peu d'investisseurs
sociaux donc je pense qu'il était
indispensable
on a vu quand même ce qui fait passer au
capitole récemment je pense qu'il est
indispensable de donner très rapidement
aux familles et aux gens les moyens de
se nourrir parce que vous savez ce n'est
pas comme un peuple n'a plus de quoi
manger et vous savez quand l'angleterre
il ya quelques années
la période d'achat tard il quand même
des périodes demi verre qui n'étaient
pas dignes de notre siècle ou du siècle
dernier
donc je pense qu'effectivement il était
urgent pour maintenir un semblant paix
sociale dans ces pays de maintenir
beaucoup plus de pouvoir d'achat
n'oublions pas quand même quand on
établit au lendemain du 11 septembre
lors de son premier discours le
président george bush a fait un discours
très fort effectivement sur le 11
septembre juste après a dit un arbre go
shopping faire que vous imaginez la
culture pire que le juste après la vie
de maintenant allez faire vos emplettes
aller faire les courses
donc on n'est pas dans le même modèle de
société bien heureusement selon moi pour
conclure 106 palombes y écoutez je
rejoins quand même sur quelques mots je
suis à coude parce que nous avons quand
même des points 2-2 rapprochement
peut-être nous noyons par les choses de
la même façon à tous niveaux
je pense que nous devons rester
optimistes que l'état français va
continuer à soutenir les entreprises que
l'europe est en marche que l'europe et
étant est en place pour réagir face il
ya eu quand même 700 milliards affectés
par le rock réparti auprès des pays
d'europe
il vaut mieux il vaut mieux être sur le
long terme il vaut mieux ne pas réagir
sur l'impulsion du moment et je pense
que nous n'avons pas de modèle
particulièrement avec le royaume uni a à
suivre nous sommes dans une politique
européenne nous sommes des européens et
nous devons rester et continuer à l'être
pour résorber la crise nous y
parviendrons
merci beaucoup à vous faites francis
palombie président de la confédération
des commerçants merci également à vous
fabrice sakoun ancien mandataire à du
medef paris et président de livingston